Staggered stalls. At least that's what I
call them. I first ran across them in a
Mel video more than 10 years ago, and
they have been a constant part of my
practice as well as my performance ever
since. And a bunch of people have asked
about them recently. So, here's a
tutorial on how to do them.
[music]
Drex here from Drexactor. PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we are
tackling the mystery of staggered stalls
and how you can perform them. But before
we dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. So, context.
Staggered stalls are something that I
picked up from Ivan Mel Gorbonoff. I
thought that they were fantastic and I
also realized that they were connected
to his horizontal stacking. So, I
figured it was useful to learn how to do
both. And ever since then, I've been
performing those staggered stalls, not
just as kind of a cool little fill in
between tricks, but also as a great way
to accompany percussion and other rapid
fire pieces of instrumentation in music.
So, how do you perform them? Well, it's
not actually as hard as you may think,
but it does require a little bit of
ingenuity. Let me show you. All right,
so to get this down, you're going to
want to make sure that you have two
[clears throat] different types of PO
stalls under your belt. Namely, you're
going to want to make sure that you know
how to perform your downstalls with the
PO pointing down towards the ground
before you change their direction as
well as upstalls when you point them up
towards the ceiling and then reverse
their direction. I have tutorials on how
to do both that I will go ahead and link
to down in the description or up in the
cards. Next up, you're going to want to
shorten up your PO. You're going to do
this by wrapping them around the knuckle
side of your hand and then back around
under the palm side of your hand. This
is going to make sure that neither one
of them is any longer than about elbow
length. And finally, you're going to
want to be real comfortable spinning the
PO in split time opposites. This is just
like a butterfly where the poi are going
in opposite directions, but you're doing
it in split time. So, they're coming
together to either side and they're
split top and bottom. All right, so
let's finally get down to the mechanics
of how this trick works. I'm going to
start things off by performing an
upstall with my right hand and bringing
it back around so that both of the poi
are spinning in split time, same
direction, clockwise. Next, I'm going to
perform an upstall with my left hand and
bring it back around. So, I wind up with
a split time butterfly, but going
outward rather than inward. Next, I'm
going to perform a downstall with my
right hand and bring it back around. So,
both of my poi are spinning in split
time, same direction, counterclockwise.
Next, I do a down stall with my left
hand. And what do you know? I am back to
that place where I am doing an inward
split time butterfly. So, let's try that
again. Right hand stalls up, left hand
stalls up, right hand stalls down, left
hand stalls down. In between, you should
always be coming back to a split time
place. Either split time opposites or
split time same direction. No matter
what, keep your timing and direction
consistent throughout, or at least your
timing. Cool. So, now I'm going to want
to work my way down from doing multiple
reps in between each stall to doing no
reps in between each stall. Going to
start off by thinking 3 2 1 right up. 3
2 1 left up. 3 2 one right down. 3 2 one
left down again. 3 2 one right up. 3 2 1
left up. 3 2 one right down. 3 2 1 left
down. I'm going to want to make sure
that I can do 10 reps of this without
messing up the order or which stall I'm
doing when. From here, I'm going to do
two beats in between each stall.
Thinking one two right up, one two left
up, one two right down, one two left
down again. One, two, right up. One,
two, left up. One, two, right down. One,
two, left down. Again, make sure you can
get in 10 reps of this and see if you
can keep your timing correct throughout.
All right, you're ready to go down to
ones now. Let's go. One right up, one
left up, one right down, one left down,
one right up, one left up, one right
down, one left down. Cool. It's starting
to take shape, isn't it? The next step
is going to be to take out the beats
entirely and just go straight between
the stalls. So, this is where the
cadence of it starts to get interesting.
You're going to want to think right,
left, right, left, right, left, right,
left, right, left. There's an
interesting kind of thing that happens
in here where when going across the
bottom, it almost looks like a
stallchaser. I think that this is kind
of an illusion, but it is a cool thing
that comes out of this just as a kind of
side effect of when you get the cadence
so it stalls correctly. So, funny thing
is there's actually two variations on
this. Remember at the beginning when I
said I was going to choose my right hand
to lead? Well, I can just as easily
choose my left hand to lead and all of
the same steps apply. So, this starts
off with an upstall with my left, coming
around to a split time, same direction,
going counterclockwise, and then an
upstall with my right, bringing me
around to an outward split time
butterfly. Then I do a down stall with
my left, and I wind up in split time,
same direction, clockwise, and a
downstall with my right to bring me back
to that split-time butterfly. So again,
the pattern is left goes up, right goes
up, left goes down, and right goes down.
And then all of the other steps still
apply until you get to a point where you
can go straight back and forth between
the whole pattern like so. Awesome. And
of course, this is a pattern that you
can get into from your stallchasers if
you just choose to go straight back and
forth in that moment that looks like a
stallchaser. This is also something that
you can do if say you're working in
split-time opposites in general. You can
pop out for a second and then straight
back into whatever split time opposites
trick you were doing before. There's a
lot of different possibilities here. So,
I highly urge you to explore and see
what you can come up with for
transitions. Wicked. I hope you enjoyed
this tutorial. If you got anything out
of this video, please make sure to like,
share, comment, and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my Flo patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for your support. You rock. And if you
would like to get your name in the
credits or access to a whole host of
other awesome rewards, you can do that
by signing up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll include a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
[music] Do please sign up and not only
will you get access to all these awesome
rewards, you'll also be helping me out
in my mission to bring po spinning and
flow arts to the whole wide world. So,
thank you in advance. And if you'd like
to learn more about how you can match up
your stalls to music, I did an entire
video on a stall exercise that you can
use to sync up your stalls to music.
I'll go ahead and include a link to that
up on screen as well as down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. [music] Peace.